eher leute ich bin echt etwas geplättet
da fing doch gestern unter dem video
über falsche fakten wieder die
diskussion über die evolutionsbiologie
an
mann mann mann mann mann ich will das
thema hierauf greifen weil es mir
wirklich am herzen liegt dass das
prinzip von wissenschaft verstanden wird
und niemand auf propaganda hereinfällt
und noch etwas ganz wichtiges
wissenschaft stellt religion nicht in
frage im gegenteil wenn die religion und
zweifelhafte theorien wie die
evolutionsbiologie in frage stellt dann
machte sich selber lächerlich und klein
ja ich bin schon mittendrin also warum
der titel dieses video so ist wie er ist
das erfahrt ihr jetzt bei klick zum
seitenwechsel herzlich willkommen
wer hätte gedacht das ist auf diesem
kanal so hoch her geht und es auch noch
politisch wird ich bin echt geplättet
dass mahlzeiten geben würde in dem
wissenschaft gerechtfertigt werden muss
das hätte ich mir nicht erträumen so
also ein kommentar hat mich jetzt
wirklich getroffen
da wurde gesagt dass ich milliarden
gläubiger herabwürdigen würde
wie bitte also noch mal von anfang an
also ich weiß auch nicht wo ich anfangen
soll
ok strukturieren als erstes wenig
erklären was wissenschaft ist und wie
sie die evolutionstheorie inzwischen
komplett ohne jeden zweifel begründet
und bewiesen hat dann erkläre ich und
weise an einem beispiel nach wir von
religiösen fundamentalisten von
autokraten und lobbygruppen manipuliert
werden und dann kommt meine meinung zur
religion und zum verhältnis zwischen
wissenschaft
da kann ich nur meine meinung sagen wann
es zum glauben an sich keine
wissenschaft geben kann gott ist nicht
beweisbar und auch das gegenteil geht
nicht und das ist auch gut so
also wissenschaft ich hatte ja vor und
das video von youtube hochgeladen
apotheker mit der richtigen botschaft
seines lebens und in diesem video
ich habe am ende verlinkt da hat er
schlüssig begründet wie wissenschaft
funktioniert warum sie fakten bürger
zweifelsfrei herausfinden oder beweisen
kampf und ews auch jeder nachvollziehen
kann das tolle ist eben auch das nicht
wissenschaftler überprüfen und
nachvollziehen können die erkenntnisse
gewonnen worden sind und ob sie stimmen
oder eben nicht stimmen ist also absolut
transparent zudem ist wissenschaft an
sich selbst kontrollierende system wie
funktioniert es also fängt mit einer
hypothese annehmen wir mal etwas
abwegiges die hypothese heißt die erde
ist flach ein wissenschaftler hat jetzt
also diese noch nicht überprüfte theorie
aufgestellt also eine mutti jetzt kommen
andere wissenschaftler und überprüfen
sie was könnte zum beispiel ein
astronaut auf der internationalen
raumstation iss sein erwägt ständig um
die erde und kann das gut überprüfen er
stellt also fest
falls sie ist kugelförmig das reicht
aber noch nicht aus es kommen astronomen
hinzu und stellen fest dass die zeiten
an denen die sonne auf- und untergeht
beim merkur venus und so weiter am
horizont auftauchen dass auch sie immer
und sind egal wie sie zu uns stehen nur
mit einer runden
zusammen passen es gibt also niemanden
der diese hypothese nachvollziehbar
bestätigen kann
wie die erste studie werden diese
untersuchung berechnung weitere studien
vor der veröffentlichung alle von
anderen wissenschaftlern kontrolliert
und nur schlüssige forschungsarbeiten
dürfen veröffentlicht werden so wird
verhindert dass irgendwelcher fantasie
kramm veröffentlicht wird im fall
unserer flachen erde hätte diese
forschungsarbeit wahrscheinlich
schwierigkeiten gehabt aber wenn die
veröffentlicht worden wären immer waren
sie wer richtig gut gegründet hätte ist
im nachgang dann so viele weitere
studien gegeben die sie eben widerlegt
hätten und wie wir am schluss ad acta
gelegt form in ganz schlimmen fällen
ziehen fachpublikationen wie auch wieder
zurück wie im falle der berühmten in
studien der behauptet wurde dass impfen
autismus verursacht und da es noch
schlimmer dem autor andrew wakefield
wurde die approbation aberkannt er darf
nicht mehr als arzt arbeiten weil er mit
seinem handeln den hippokratischen eid
verletzt hat denn jeder arzt leistet
indem er eben geschworen hat sich nur
für das wohl der menschen einzusetzen
sein handeln
er versucht weiter menschen von seinem
früheren team zu überzeugen
tut er das eben nicht mehr sondern
verursacht den tod von menschen so fällt
also eine abwegige hypothese beispiel 2
nehmen wir doch mal die
evolutionstheorie charles darwin hat sie
als erster formuliert seine theorie war
es gibt einen einfachen mechanismus der
leben hier auf der erde sich immer
weiter entwickeln wird die theorie in
jeder generation entwickeln sich
veränderungen der ursprünglichen spezies
so genannte mutationen die die
überlebenschance ihr spezielles
verbessern werden weiter getragen weil
die wir das nicht tun oder sogar
verschlechtern dieses exemplar früher
sterben lassen also wenn jemand keine
ahnung irgendwelche veränderungen an
seinem körper hat und früher stirbt kann
er als das nicht weiter tragen also zum
beispiel den galapagos vögeln sie dass
sie die sich verbessert haben entwickelt
sich weiter die schlechtere hermann
lange haben können sie nicht weitergehen
muss sterben früher einfach und
wirkungsvoll ist dieses prinzip der
evolution der kampf des lebens ist vage
lauf live das ist jetzt ziemlich
simplifiziert die basis aber ist wir
sind hier auf der erde aus der ursuppe
entstanden deren moleküle immer komplett
verboten und schließlich die dna
bildeten die in der lage ist unser
erbgut zu speicher zu duplizieren und
weiterzugeben
unabhängig ob es hier immer wieder neue
erkenntnisse gibt stammbaum über
umgeschrieben werden müssen ist immer
neue forschung dazu mutationen entstehen
und so weiter ein es ist immer wieder
bestätigt worden und zwar so aus dass
kein ernstzunehmender wissenschaftler
sie in zweifel ziehen würde
sie ist absolut zweifelsfrei bewiesen
durch paläontologie genetik morphologie
anatomie zellbiologie biochemie biologie
ökologie biogeographie und
entwicklungsbiologie ist absolute
gewissheit und zwar so gewesen und jetzt
kommen wir zur religion dass die
katholische kirche anerkannt hat
aber wieso hält sich dann immer weiter
die skepsis gegenüber dieser theorie
diese gibt es leute die meinen dass sie
gar nicht bewiesen sei wieso wird sie
immer öfter kritisiert ich möchte
dahinter steckt eine ganz perfide
tendenz verschwörungstheoretiker würden
jetzt wahrscheinlich von einer klar
verschwörung reden zumindest haben
einige leute herausgefunden wie wir
wieder zurück ins mittelalter kommen
können nach sehr fortgeschrittene
zivilisation und kulturen wie dem
römischen reich der griechischen
demokratie waren wir in ein dunkles
zeitalter zurückgefallen die menschen
waren total einfach zu manipulieren die
kirche die herrscher wurden von
autokraten und diktatoren dominiert die
nur nach ihrem eigenen vorteil strecken
den war ein dummes ungebildete volk
gerade recht es konnte nach lust und
laune manipuliert werden und genau auf
diesem weg sind wir so viel des
informationen wie im letzten jahr habe
ich noch nicht erlebt gegen
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse werden
irgendwelche behauptungen aufgestellt
den klimawandel gäbe es nicht die
evolutionstheorie würde nicht stimmen
und so weiter im mittelalter hat das
alles zu schlimmen katastrophen geführt
der dreißigjährige krieg und die pest
und in ländern wie der türkei den usa
russland ungarn und so weiter und so
fort sind wir genau da hin wieder
unterwegs und wie manipulieren wir uns
gestern wurde in den kommentaren ein
phänomenales beispiel verlinkt eine
liste mit 700 wissenschaftler die
zweifel an der evolutionstheorie hätten
wirklich ein ganz schlimmer versuch der
manipulation er nimmt die wissenschaft
hier als feigenblatt um skepsis
gegenüber unzweifelhaften
wissenschaftlichen erkenntnissen zu
streuen
dabei ist die überprüfung ganz einfach
ist das eine wissenschaftliche studie
wurde sie überprüft nein
abgehakt einfach abgehakt ist
bedeutungslos und wenn man dann genau
hinschaut ist sie auch wirklich bresche
die wissenschaftler arbeiten zum teil
gar nicht an den genannten renommierten
universitäten zum teil arbeiten sie gar
nicht wissenschaftlich wie stellen nur
0,01 prozent der fachleute auf den
fachgebieten da die sich mit der
evolutionstheorie beschäftigen und so
weiter und so fort aber das entscheiden
wir es dass für mich alles gar nicht
wichtig und nur das zählt es ist
unwissenschaftlich und somit nicht zu
berücksichtigen das wäre so als würde
vor ist ein tisch stehen und legen ihr
sagt jemand
ich glaube nicht dass da endlich steht
das spielt einfach keine rolle glauben
tut man in der kirche ja und glauben hat
im wissenschaftsbetrieb einfach nichts
zu suchen so und jetzt wissenschaft und
kirche wir haben ja schon gehört der
vatikan hat die evolutionstheorie
anerkannt und nicht wieder so ein kino
war wie damals mit galileo galilei over
anstalt da wissen wir ja woher das kam
warum geht die katholische kirche so
locker damit um warum wird ihre kirche
davon ich in den grundfesten erschüttert
ganz einfach bei glaube nichts damit zu
tun hat ob irgendeine theorie in der
bibel anders dargestellt wurden oder
nicht es geht um den kern des glaubens
und jeder der sich an so etwas wie der
evolutionstheorie aufhängen der macht
gott und seinen glauben so so schlimm
klein das ist ganz erbärmlich ihr habt
ja inzwischen gemerkt wie groß
wissenschaft ist wie unglaublich mit
seriösen gewandert ist
da ist so viel platz für gott da muss
niemand kleingeistig an der
schöpfungsgeschichte festhalten und was
ist denn der kern des glaubens
es ist etwas das nicht in unseren genen
es ist etwas das uns erst zum menschen
macht und dass religion auf dem zug
dienst menschlichen kern bringt gnade
im gegensatz zum range of life können
dass menschen nämlich und ist etwas
wunderbares und service und das sollten
wir feiern leben in form von aufnahme
von flüchtlingen dem schutz der umwelt
frieden auf erden und viele mehr
und das fehlt all diesen diktatoren und
autokraten wie immer mehr an die macht
kommt und dass wir wissenschaft hier
nicht in frage stellen lassen ist etwas
ganz wichtiges wenn wir gegen diese
leute etwas tun wollen die uns
manipulieren
denn dann ist der manipulation in
zukunft tür und tor geöffnet
falls nicht auf die rattenfänger rein
ach ja und den titel habe ich genau so
gewählt weil das die situation ist es
gibt einfach keinen zweifel an der
evolutionstheorie und der kreationismus
der steht auf seinem posten und jeder
der möchte kann das überprüfen einfach
lesen leben und ihr werdet feststellen
die evolutionstheorie ist der wirklich
zweifelsfrei bewiesen wenn ihr die
diskussion zum thema
wissenschaftstheorie fake news
verschwörungstheorien und so weiter
verfolgen wollen dann sollten wir hier
ein abo aufs auge und vergessen auf die
glocke nicht wenn er kein video zu
diesem thema verpassen wollt hier geht
es zum video von youtube heißen dick
drauf wenn ihr wissen wollt was die
wichtigste botschaft meines lebens ist
und 4
sag ich jetzt bis dann blatter